foreign
work this is the Ramsay show where we
help you get control of your money get
ahead in your career and get on the path
to Living Well I'm George Campbell your
host joined today by best-selling author
host of The Rachel crew show you guessed
it it's Rachel Cruz and we are excited
to take your calls about life and money
at Triple Eight and
5225 that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Nick joins us up first
in Birmingham Alabama Nick welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey George and Rachel how you all doing
today we're doing great how can we help
um good well I uh real quick uh I just
wanted to say that my wife and I paid
off all of our student loans uh last
year and
um you know that's created so much
positive momentum for us and we're going
to be paying off the house within the
next couple years and so we don't regret
it one bit Yeah
way to go man how can we help today
yeah so uh kind of along the same lines
um I have a couple of young kids and
um I have a five-year-old and a
two-year-old and I was just curious with
with these um these morons in Washington
keep on making these student loans and
people keep on accepting them I guess a
concern of mine is uh tuition cost is
going to Skyrocket over the next 10 15
years and so I was just wondering if you
had any feedback or advice on how to
um uh look at these 529 planes in terms
of how much to contribute when is enough
enough is college even going to
um you know make sense in 15 years and
uh just want to see if y'all had any
feedback on that
yeah well the college discussion I mean
it's an interesting one not just because
of the news in the last 48 hours but
also I think that there was there was
conversations before that happens
on what is college going to be I mean
the questions that you're asking Nick I
think we all kind of are I'm like I
don't know a picture of Education my
kids are exactly your kids ages and I'll
tell you my husband I still contribute
to a 529 for each of our three kids
we're still doing the path because at
the end of the day I'm like money
invested in the apps uh if they choose
to go to college it's going to be there
and we kind of will continue to check in
on that throughout the years because it
is going to be a lengthy process right
still 10 15 years till that happens uh
but I I mean there's a little bit of me
I'm like it's a question mark of what
education is going to look like what
it's going to be like uh what the pro
yeah what the price is going to do is it
going to continue to go up or is there
going to be a huge backlash from our
culture and I mean what your kids will
want to study and where they'll want to
go to school and honestly the trade
routes has become even more popular uh
you know even if you want to get into
you know coding and make great money you
just gotta go to code school and then
you don't need a college degree so so
it's just fascinating I feel like what
the discussion is as a culture Nick but
I I can just tell you what I'm doing we
are continuing to fund a 529 for our
kids because I do think at the end of
the day
um if there is a question I think having
a college degree having higher education
I think it is a great thing and if I can
provide the financial assistance
alongside my kids uh I am going to do
that but I think it is I mean and all of
us Ramsay personalized even kind of
different various opinions Ken would
probably say give a different answer
than I would but and delony's got a
different opinion on education and but
yeah what do you think George I just
think we can prepare for the future
without worrying about the future and a
lot of people they're doing both and
sometimes that means they're doing less
preparing and more worrying and so the
fact that you're even calling and
wondering about this at with a five and
two year old makes me feel like all
right Nick's got a game plan you're on
track to pay off your house we're on
track to save for college now if you had
a 17 year old and you haven't even
talked about college I'd be more worried
right now but the fact that you are
getting ahead of this thing and if you
just contribute to this 529 and go all
right our goal is to have a hundred
thousand dollars by the time time
they're 18 and let's see what things do
as they get there over the next you know
12 15 years
and at that point we'll have a much
better picture of what your kids are
going to be going after they may want to
go into the trades and they can still
use that money towards that you can
change the beneficiary in the 529
anytime it can be used for anyone in the
family so I'm less worried about
overfunding it and I'm more worried
about underfunding it so I think it's
okay to lean towards the other side
okay awesome well thank you so much for
your help yeah absolutely man thanks for
the call yeah the best thing you can do
as a parent in in my eyes Rachel
obviously you have kids and they're
young and so you're thinking about this
stuff but it's having the conversations
early and helping them figure out what
that path is because a lot of kids just
wander into a degree they think sounds
good that they think will pay well with
a job at the end of it without actually
figuring out what am I wired to do what
am I passionate about what would fuel me
versus what would put food on the table
that too but also to be like a little
bit against that I'm like at 18 how do
you know you don't right like that's
what's hard too is is you get a degree
and I even have a great friend and she
got an accounting degree so she's an
accountant very successful but she hates
it and she's like but I got a degree in
this this is all I've done and so like
it's just I do hate that I'm like as
these 18 year olds you kind of get boxed
in or the pressure of like you better
have it all figured out at 18. I know
but then also it's like yeah but
getting a college degree in in a lot of
fields helps you you're gonna sink a lot
of money and time to the next yeah so it
is it's a it's an interesting uh
perspective to really look into and what
what is the ROI of a college degree
these days and to your point though also
what are you passionate about I mean we
I know kids that they're like school's
just not my thing it's not my thing and
some parents force them to still go get
a four-year degree uh some don't I mean
it's just it's it's a fascinating
conversation and then in the last 48
hours too it's uh it's kind of blown up
and my so the culture I grew up in with
it was a middle eastern culture and it's
very much you're kind of pressured to go
be an engineer or go be in medicine
because those are good respectable
reputable fields that pay well and it
ends up great for a lot of those people
but a lot of times you wake up after you
get your degree and you go I don't want
to be an engineer this is not what I was
put on Earth to do and so there's both
sides we don't want to put too much
pressure on the kids but we also don't
want to just let them figure it out on
their own we can help them along the way
exactly well said well said all right
let's go to Shawna in Chicago Sean
welcome to the show
hi hi guys happy Friday you as well how
can we help
oh yeah so I had a cool question so I'm
24 years old I've been living at home
with the parents and I'm actually
interested in moving out soon
um I'm deb3 I have 13 000 saved for a
move out budget this was just like a
cushion for rent in case I was going to
go to rent but I'm also now thinking
about maybe putting that as a down
payment on a condo and I'm not like
teeter-tottering on whether it would be
better to like rent Chicago's rent is
ridiculously expensive here and I've
been thinking about like either you know
renting or buying and I really do want
to buy because I want to own some Equity
but tell me what you guys think is that
your emergency fund too
oh great and John do you see yourself in
that area for
the foreseeable future
definitely uh definitely around yeah
around the Chicagoland area yeah well I
can tell you the formula we we kind of
run the numbers through when it comes to
getting a mortgage is that you on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage you put down
you know
if you're a new homeowner it could be
five ten percent if you can hit that 20
that's great because you can avoid PMI
and that your monthly payment is no more
your mortgage payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay so if you
find something in that range I would be
totally fine if you if you decide to buy
I think that that's great I think moving
out of your parents house too Sean is
great I know people kind of uh that's
part of their story as they transition
into real life but I think you get a
sense of like adulthood and dignity when
you're like okay I'm on my own and I
think I encourage that greatly so if
you're not quite at that formula renting
is totally fine until you have enough
money saved for a good dump payment and
making sure you get what you want yeah
jump on our website Sean we've got a
great mortgage calculator and you might
need to rent for another year and stack
up cash but that is the wise thing to do
if that's what you got to do thanks for
the call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for ways to update your home without
blowing the budget I've got it for years
I've been telling you about our friends
at blinds.com blinds.com makes it simple
to shop top quality blinds Shades and
interior shutters from home with easy
online ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show this is
your friendly reminder that you can come
visit us and watch the show live We just
hung out with a bunch of the guests out
there that came by to see us we're just
south of Nashville Tennessee we've got
free baked goods free coffee a free mug
there's a timeline history wall and you
can watch the show on the glass and we
come out every every hour so come hang
out with us in Asheville if you're in
the area
it's a free call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm George
Campbell joined today by Rachel Cruz
we're taking your calls on life and
money Annie joins us up next in Topeka
Kansas Annie welcome to the show
hi um I was just wondering if um with my
refund check from the government for
student loans if I should use it toward
my mortgage or if I should use it to be
generous or help somebody out that's a
very sweet question now Annie this is
all conjecture right this is theoretical
if and when you get the refund yes okay
I was like did you already get the
refund of my hearing things okay I did
talk to my loan provider and they're
like okay we issued the refund you
should see it in your account wow this
is big news
yeah it's like whoa so you guys are in
baby steps four five and six
yes okay how much is left on the
mortgage
um
two a lot we just bought the house okay
cool cool cool and you're wondering
should I be generous what do I do with
the money when I get it is your question
right okay
well I would apply it to the baby steps
and if you want to give a portion of
that I think it's a great thing to do if
that's what your your hearts are driving
you towards uh but definitely apply it
to that mortgage do you know if it's
gonna be a certain amount is it 10
yes okay cool Rachel what are your
thoughts my husband is going to apply as
well so and he's got he would get
another 10 there
yes cool yeah that's great I would just
keep throwing it I would yeah you
definitely can give some for sure I mean
obviously there's never
a negative when you're when you're
giving uh and so using that using the
remainder though to continue to whether
you guys are are saving up
um to replace a car if that's in the if
that's in the equation if there's any
big purchase coming up you can obviously
use it for that or yeah just throw it
there at the mortgage at baby step six
uh would be very smart I don't feel good
to see that balance go down
yes awesome well thanks so much for the
question Annie appreciate it
Lois uh is it Lois joins us in San Jose
did I get that right
yes you did George and it's the Lois
that you met before thank you for taking
my call oh wonderful how are you doing
today
I'm doing great
um I was there June 10th for my dead
free cream yes so my question yes
um so I am just about to complete baby
step three and I am saving for a new car
as you know the craziness in California
we are going to stop all the Gaspard
cars I want to get a
reliable electric car so I am trying to
save for that and I wanted to know how
the thinking comes work that's my
question today I've had Dave talk about
it but I am not very familiar with how
it works how close are you to finishing
baby step three with the fully funded
emergency fund
so I'm hoping by end of September and I
wanted to see for another maybe three
months or four months for my car
great so by end of December yeah do you
have a number in mind of how much you're
you're wanting to spend on that car
I want to uh spend 20 000. 20 000. okay
what's your income
my income and I just got a pay raise
thanks to God I have luck with you guys
um so it's going to be 230 000. wow
that's awesome are you married
yes I'm married fantastic way to go you
guys are crushing through these baby
steps and I would say it's it's getting
time for the upgrade in the car and
you're you've definitely decided
electric which you know Rachel and I are
fans
yep we love it good we love a good
plug-in car it's great do you have
Rachel and I both uh we are famously now
Tesla owners because Dave Rags on us on
air every chance he gets that we drive
batteries with wheels
as I plug in next to his truck buy a
Tesla two years ago on credit until I
met Dave and Rachel and everyone oh
thank goodness we saved you
that's awesome so good so good so that's
so great well to answer your question
you know house thinking funds work it
really is just putting a specific number
aside every month until you reach your
goals so I don't know if there's a I
know you said you kind of have a time
frame which is great but it would just
be backing out of that and saying okay
you know over the next if you're gonna
put four thousand a month in a savings
account in five months we'll have twenty
thousand dollars
okay okay so that's how it works yes
it's pretty simple yeah
and some people I think George you might
be one of these people that opens up a
separate account yeah I do like to have
a separate savings account because you
can do them online yes very easily just
open a new savings account yeah and put
it in there that way it's not in there
with your emergency fund and with the
Christmas fund and it gets a little
jumbled yes so that stresses George out
so if you want a separate savings
account for this you totally can do that
or if you just keep track of it and no
okay I'm putting this money aside and I
know I'm gonna be writing a check for a
new car in five months and it's going to
be this amount and it's great so it
really is just planning ahead and saying
I need to set aside a specific amount of
money per month to reach my goal when my
goal comes I love it thanks so much for
the question Lois and I I wish you luck
in finding a Tesla for twenty thousand
dollars if you do call us back I will be
very very impressed you may need to
spend a little more than that but with
your income you guys could swing it it
may mean waiting another month or two
and spending 30. California I don't know
I I shouldn't speak honest I don't know
it that well but I saw it come through
that yeah that they're wanting they
don't want to
sell gas powered cars I want to say wow
in the next like decade I think it's
like
in 20.35 thank you producer James so low
so you have a little bit of time you got
a little bit of time so even if you
wanted to you know save over eight
months and save some more money and get
a different electric car what stage of
life that car is at well sure that's
true all right thanks for the call
Natalie joins us up next in Virginia
Beach Natalie welcome to the show
hi thank you
um
husband and I are we have a chunk of
change in our savings account
um should we pay down our mortgage or if
we're contemplating moving within the
next three-ish years
should we continue to save up to put a
bigger down payment on a future home
which will probably have a higher
interest rate
interesting well I would tell you to put
it towards the current mortgage
because when you sell your current home
to buy your new home whatever was at the
equity you could use that as the down
payment as well
well that's a another
um snippet we would like to keep this
home and use it as a rental in the
future gotcha okay well that does change
that changes some of it because I would
want that current home that you guys are
in completely paid off
um we don't want you to have too much I
don't want you to have two mortgages
is lower
say again
even if the interest rate would probably
be significantly lower yes even if the
interest rate slower yeah having two
mortgages is not is not ideal so I
either if you guys want to get in the
real estate game you could again put
this extra money the savings you have on
your current mortgage sell the house use
some of it for a down payment and then
even say okay let's save up or maybe you
get the next house you have you put 20
down whatever's remaining
um that you yeah what am I trying to say
for the investment property just to pay
with cash for the for the investment
property so like basically if you want
to kind of dip your toe into that world
getting something even just like a condo
I mean you could do something uh and pay
cash for it because whenever you do uh
investment real estate we always
recommend doing it with cash and
starting small uh so that could be the
option that you guys want to do but no I
would not keep your current home and buy
a new home and have two mortgages
because the rental
the rental idea it sounds great and a
lot of people think like oh yeah it's
easy money and it is pay the mortgage
for me Rachel it's great passive income
but then you don't realize oh wow
there's actual people that are living
there and they may not pay or I have to
find new wrenches it ends up being
almost like a part-time job yeah yeah so
uh just to give you guys some breathing
room and margin and cushion I would not
I would not have two mortgages yeah I'd
focus on one thing right now and that is
paying off your current mortgage as fast
as you can and I like doing it towards
the current mortgage because it's a
forced savings plan it creates automatic
discipline because the money's not
floating out there and you can use it
towards who knows what but I love the
spirit of the question and I hope you
guys become Real Estate Investors very
very soon thanks so much for the
question triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm George camel
that's Rachel Cruz we are here for you
give us a call this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
State and I want you to have a house but
I don't want a house to have you that's
why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsay
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
[Music]
I'm George Campbell host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by Rachel Cruz host of The
Rachel crew show you can find all of
those shows including this one the
Ramsay show on the Ramsey Network and
wherever you listen to podcasts
all right Rachel it's it's Friday we
like to have some fun and that means
reacting to videos on the internet that
James sends us and the latest one is a
fun one because it's Gary vaynerchuk who
I find personally very entertaining yes
generally insightful he's got a potty
mouth so you know luckily this clip is
this clip is safe it's radio friendly
guys don't the FCC is not coming after
us but he's talking about investing now
he's a social media expert entrepreneur
author speaker but he's big into the
trendy Investments of the day including
nfts and crypto and all that very cool
so we yes he's very cool we disagree on
a lot of things in that in the financial
space but he had something interesting
to say because he does have his finger
on the pulse of the trends that are
happening out there among the Youth of
America so let's see what Gary has to
say the youth if you go look at Tick
Tock accounts of 15 16 17 year olds you
have 16 year olds that have in their bio
investor and I'm like this is profound
what I'm seeing is a bigger combo the
rise of people saying I'm an investor
too and then the rise of what they want
to invest in so now you've got 15 to 30
year olds that think about investing but
they don't want to buy a one-family
bedroom and make recurring revenue on
rent they want to buy a pair of Nikes
that are going to go up 2x they want to
buy John Morant rookie cards they want
the nft to put in their social media
profile and they want it to go up that's
very different than buying 75 shares of
Turner because investing is now more pop
culture and fashion everyone now sees it
as a viable cultural thing you do and
they just are going to do it in new
stuff so alternative Investments that is
a big deal and it hasn't begun
interesting and it hasn't begun he's
teasing it Rachel this is the future
we're living in it's no longer just
Pokemon cards I feel like people always
kind of did that kind of stuff though I
mean not like nfts obviously but I feel
like but now with social media it's a
different ball game because it's like a
flex now yeah to have this facade of
like I'm an investor like that's who I
am such a funny word I knew a guy uh one
of my cousin's friends and he would come
to Nashville drive to Nashville because
we have a Nike outlet in Cool Springs
outside of Nashville and he would come
and like raka and he had an online store
and he would sell shoes that was like
his thing and he'd drive around but he
also had like a full-time job but it was
like the side thing it's side Hustle but
I feel like it paid pretty well so I'm
like I mean great that's awesome well
these people are passionate about a
certain little you know Niche and
weathered shoes or nfts and they kind of
make it a side house only make a little
money and sometimes it turns into a
full-time gig for some people yeah and
it's not a bad thing but it can't be
your only thing like when you're still
not in my opinion and investing in the
things that have a long track record
that are predictable that you know
what's going to happen
uh aka the market or 401ks raw fire is
like like especially with retirement
like that stuff for me is still a
no-brainer and then once you've done
that and you want to go dabbling
something with some money knowing it's
kind of a gamble
um I mean that's your prerogative that's
what you want to do but yes but it's
fascinating that how it's trendy though
which I kind of appreciate I'm like I'm
so glad money has become like being so
cool to talk about now yes which is fun
but there is a piece of this where
anything you know I've I've said if you
follow the trends you will fall for the
traps and that is my worry with what's
happening is that these folks are
falling into nfts and they spend two
thousand dollars on an nft and they go
to try to resell it and nobody wants it
for ten dollars and that's what we're
seeing which is happening yes that whole
industry it's a reality that I was
worried about absolutely tanked
absolutely tanked so that's it's all a
gamble like when you're doing something
new and what's on Trend it's a gamble
you have to know that so don't so we're
not mad at that stuff just to be clear
we're not like no those get off my lawn
it's just more of a you know if you're
following our baby steps you're
investing 15 of your income into
retirement meaning your 401ks your IRAs
mutual funds before we start going all
right we're gonna have some play money
we're gonna invest in some shoes some
crypto we're not mad at that but don't
make that your investing plan overall
that is not a good strategy because
honestly the crypto and the nft the way
it's gone is not good not good at all
not good so I I know someone Rachel very
personally who put their entire life
savings stop it into Dogecoin no no
we're talking over four hundred thousand
dollars George I'm right here James is
right there I wish I could say it was
James that'd make me it wouldn't make me
happy I don't want any I don't wish that
for James James but out of all the smart
people in my life that's not James
that 400 something thousand turned into
80 000. oh man and now they are in debt
to Fidelity for hundreds of thousands of
dollars for margin calls and it's greed
is what it comes down to yeah it's get
rich quick and it's what we rally
against every day here at Ramsey
solutions for 30 years Dave has been
rallying against this culture of get
rich quick and the trends change it used
to be zero down real estate and gold and
buy this course and now it's sneakers
yeah who knew who knew so it's part of
what we do at our Building Wealth event
Rachel which we didn't mean this is not
a pitch but it's what we do at this
Building Wealth event we've been taking
around the country we've got four or
five of these events this fall and Dave
does a great talk about what he's seen
in 30 years when it comes to investing
in get rich quick and then we lay out
the plan to get rich the right way and
it's usually a lot slower and slower and
not as exciting can we say that George I
feel like we would have a very exciting
message we were like had a webinar a
seminar we had all the youth in America
there and we were like you're 401K guys
it's gonna get you they're all going to
stare at us and leave I know and go buy
nfts we're like go go funder 401K it's
so great 10 in 20.
this is awesome this nft these sneakers
all of it like this is the future this
is what's happening and it might right
like I'm I'm at the humble opinion
things may change I'm not mad I need at
least a long track record before I go
and put my own money in it yes
and so that that is the bigger issue and
these 16 17 year old 18 year olds
they're living with mom and dad probably
and some of them are amazing
entrepreneurs and I'm like these are the
kids we're all going to be working for
one day these are really sharp amazing
kids and what I want for them is to have
a long-term success not short-term
success and flail out and they're also
trying to pay off their student loan
debt because they wandered into that and
they also have credit card debt in a car
loan because they're flexing for the
gram and so this is where it becomes
you're doing too many things at once
you're never going to build wealth that
way that lasts yep so there's my soapbox
for the day it's a great so we did it I
think it's exciting and cool George
garyvee culture might not but I think
you're cool George wow clip that one out
guys I'm Gonna Save that all right Zach
joins us in Birmingham Zach welcome to
the show
thank you guys
um I appreciate you guys taking my call
sure
um my I'm going to preface this with I
uh just drank the Ramsay juice
um my wife has been preaching this for a
while
um but I'm on board now so awesome
um we are on baby step two
um I
just recently sat down and built a
budget
um with uh every dollar and
um we have about 29
000 in student loans
um that I just finished my masters with
and we have just a couple of thousand
dollars in like medical bills from a
recent birth of our child
um my question to you is is our
her parents have offered to to give us a
thirty thousand dollars for the student
loan so it doesn't collect
um any
money um any uh
interest um over the next couple of
years and our goal is to pay that off
within the next year
um is this a loan from your parents
this is a loan yes from the from her
parents um just to pay it off and so
they don't collect interest
um and so we have our plan is to accept
that
um I from my understanding you may not
suggest doing that but my other question
is those the other couple of thousands
and um debt is not
um
collecting interest is a medical bills
so it's just on a payment plan
um
what do I still keep my six percent
out of my my match 401K so do I
completely not contribute to that since
this money is not taxable or I'm not
gaining interest or do I go hey Zach how
much how much how much you make a year
sure I make a hundred and five to 110
000 a year awesome Zach so no do not
take the loan from the parents suddenly
you become in this entangled
relationship where you owe them money
and the borrower slave to lender changes
everything you guys make great money I
would knock all of this out in the next
401k and then pause the 401K knock all
the set out press play on the 401K a
year from now once you're debt free and
have a fully funded emergency fund you
guys can do this you're trying to math
your way out of it just focus pay it off
and you guys get ahead on your own
because you can you can Zach you guys
got this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
folks with the rising cost of everything
these days a lot of people are worried
about not having enough money in their
bank accounts to get through the month
and the good news is no matter where
you're at with your money today and no
matter the state of the economy you can
get on a path to Building Wealth at our
Building Wealth live events you'll learn
simple Common Sense principles to build
real lasting wealth and this tour is
it's going swimmingly we've already sold
out two nights and the rest of these
events are on track to sell out real
soon so if you're thinking about joining
us do not wait to get your tickets
Phoenix September 12th that's a new one
we added so you can get tickets to that
because the next night the 13th is sold
out Sacramento November 1st sold out
Minneapolis November 10th we've got a
few tickets left and San Antonio to
finish out the season on November 15th
passes start at just 25 bucks or you can
get a four pack starting at sixty
dollars go to ramseysolutions.com events
to reserve your seats now Rachel Cruz
will be there I'll be there Dave Ramsey
Ken Coleman John the whole gang and it's
a really really fun time and we love
being out there meeting you all across
the country ramseysolutions.com events
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window covering you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from David in North Dakota my wife and I
have been married for a few years and
are discussing having children currently
we have individual medical plans through
our employers since it's cheaper my
coverage is with a high deductible plan
which allows me to contribute to an HSA
my my wife wants to be a stay-at-home
mom so the entire family would be
enrolled through my employer
since children have significantly higher
medical expenses do I individual than I
do individually would make more sense to
stick with the high deductible plan and
pay for larger medical expenses out of
pocket or my HSA funds or should we
switch to a high premium lower
deductible plan to cover the known large
expenses
the old Insurance question it's a
classic it's a cloud
so this is something that my wife and I
do currently here at Ramsey we have the
employer sponsored Healthcare High
deductible health care plan within HSA
and we do it individually because we
don't have kids so it's actually cheaper
yeah and so he's saying hey once we go
my wife stays at home it's all on me I'm
on a family plan now do I stick with
that HSA high high deductible plan or
switch to the higher premium lower
deductible plan and we usually say if
you have a lot of known health issues
medical things going on you're better
off with a higher premium lower
deductible but we just don't know yeah
what life's going to look like these
kids could be very healthy and you might
be better off with the high today yeah
you have the cash available and you guys
especially are in a place where you're
like yeah we have an emergency fund if
something like huge happens uh I yeah I
would tend to say the higher deductible
and pay out of pocket so you're paying
lower monthly
um or your your health insurance you
know for everything else is lower when
you're paying for it so any of the
difference with whatever the premium
costs it's going to be a lower premium
so you can take the difference and put
that that's right
totally totally and the HSA is one of my
favorite things the health savings
account because it's Triple Tax Benefit
it goes in tax-free it grows tax-free
you withdraw it tax-free and you can
invest the money once it's past a
certain threshold which is awesome yes
it can be part of retirement it is yeah
totally yeah use it so that's what
that's what I would say I would still
stick with a higher deductible
especially if you guys are in a good
financial position and you can always
switch it later on if you if there's
known medical issues that come up it may
make more sense to switch but for now
I'm sticking with the high deductible
plan with the HSA that's my final answer
finally if this was Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire love that show 50 50. George
all right let's go to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Marie joins us in Myrtle Beach Marie
welcome to the Ramsay show
yes thank you for taking my call
um I am 65. I will reach the full
retirement
um age early next year in April I still
work full time
um I do have an emergency fund I also
still have a mortgage
um but I only have about a hundred
thousand in retirement
so I'd like to get your advice on I'm on
business and I'd like to when I started
on Social Security next year I'd like to
cut back a little bit and I'm not
talking much but maybe a third
um of how much time you're spending in
the business
yes which would lower your interest
because I'm kind of own burnout um a
little bit what's your current income
well
I've I'm
now
um wanted to report on your taxes
um well my daddy
hands of a small small amount and then
so let's say 40K I believe it
that's how much I pay myself through W-2
okay what's left on the mortgage
uh 2 30. okay 230. how much do you have
in the business Marie
you say you're paying yourself a small
salary I'm assuming everything else is
are you investing it back in the
business like is that other money being
spent or are you is it in a well I have
very low low overhead in the business
um so I leave all the I mean I'm
typically there's about uh 50 000 in
cash in the business pretty much at all
times
in a savings account
no just in the checking account okay
cool and you're asking us how can I
retire with some dignity here knowing I
have a hundred thousand dollars to my
name
right right well yeah I mean I don't see
myself ever just completely not working
unless unless I can't for some reason
but you know I I've really not done a
good job obviously of and I don't have
any other debt except for my mortgage
um and I just like some advice on how
can I build that up I'm throwing
everything I can at the mortgage of the
principal and the mortgage each month to
try to get that down
how much uh you how much Equity do you
have in the house so you said you owe
230 in the mortgage what's the house
worth
I mean I believe right now I could get
about five out of it
okay do you live alone
yes okay
I'm wondering because this is a pretty
massive mortgage to be heading into
retirement could you sell and buy
something with cash with the remaining
let's call it 230.
yeah yeah I mean I've listened to a day
long enough that I knew that probably
was going to be the one option at least
um you know the reason my mortgage is so
high is because really a couple years
ago the opportunity to be in in my in my
retirement
home it just kind of fell in my lap and
I was like okay I'm just going to do
this probably maybe not the best
decision but
you know so when I started thinking
about that I'm like okay do I
you know do I give up what I considered
to be my retirement home
yes because I mean this mortgage Marie I
mean it's not going to allow you to
really retire because it's going to take
you right a long time to pay it off and
you don't have you know you have a you
know a hundred thousand dollars which is
great that that's that's what you have
but
um in a case this house could be things
stopping you to retire like if you could
imagine yes living somewhere else but
not having a mortgage suddenly what you
have to earn per month to live
significantly goes down when you don't
have a mortgage payment that you have to
worry about it changes it changes the
scope of your retirement I mean it
really does and I think our homes we get
so emotionally
attached to them because they are I mean
they're a sacred place in our lives it's
the you know it's it's our homes uh but
what ends up happening is we put so much
stock of our happiness in these four
walls versus what you actually create in
a home and so I think I would love to
see you be able to retire early with a
with a sense that you're you don't have
to worry about paying for a mortgage and
that would be including selling the
house yeah the theme Here is that this
house is not the dream you thought it
would be because you're not gonna be
able to put food on the table and
survive but you get to live in this
house so we're gonna have to make some
hard decisions here but you can retire
with dignity we just have to make some
sacrifices to get there you got it Marie
thanks for the call that puts this hour
of the Ramsay show in the books foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Network this is the Ramsay show where we
help you get control of your money get
ahead in your career and get on the path
to Living Well I'm George Campbell your
host joined today by Ramsay personality
Rachel Cruz and we are so excited to
take your call today so give us one
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
eight eight two five five two two five
Rachel is uh she's sipping on Americano
from the Ramsey Cafe she's eating a
chocolate chip cookie we're having a
good time I've been joined by Friday
she's really living I am not a cop I'm
over here pulling all the weight Rachel
can you pick up some slack just know I
am not a coffee snob I'm like give me a
Keurig
coffee it's like I'm good I am good I
thought you had give me a Waffle House
black coffee plant like anything I'm
just I'm just no cream no sugar just
bought coffee anyways I have been our
Cafe
they do great fancy drinks and I always
just get a black coffee anywhere I go
but the old Americano you can't beat it
it's a James child's original favorite
his favorite he's an American avocados
you like an Americano yeah I do yeah
yeah especially iced uh oh this is why
people tune into the show guys you
thought you were coming here for some
Financial advice some life-changing
information we just found out our
producer James Child's favorite drink
that's all let's go to the phones where
we are more useful Brandon joins us in
Jackson Mississippi Brandon welcome to
the show
hey hey how's it how's it going we're
doing great man how can we help
yeah so currently in my life right now I
am about to start a new job and I.T I'm
making about 40 000 base pay
uh but the main issue right now is that
I
I do still live with my my parents right
now at 29 and I I fell victim to the the
trend of Van life if you've ever heard
of that what is it van life van life
yeah we don't like living a van and not
down by the river but you like travel
around the country with it right is that
what you're talking about yeah basically
yeah go to the van and put like a like a
whole living stuff that was like a whole
life insurance company yeah I wasn't
sure you're literally talking about I
bought a van I'm gonna live in it
tell us why that was a bad idea
I can tell you quite a few reasons why
first of all where are you gonna
actually stay once you have it they're
figured out and converted but uh and
really the biggest problem now is just
debt because I was dumb enough to
uh take out a loan with Chrysler Capital
and uh I used to work retail uh not too
long ago but
I I still end up like uh like 30 000. is
that all of your debt
yes okay no student loans no credit
cards no other cars no is this your only
vehicle
well here's the thing I I do still live
with my parents and they do have a
vehicle that barely works but it is
better than nothing as far as commuting
to my new job
and we're trying to get that fixed up uh
just as a
you know this is a staff Gap what's the
van worth
so the van I bought it at
I would say
35 no no no no no I think it was around
40. so the van was you bought for 40.
what could you sell it for today
I really I really don't know and I'm
trying to figure out like what would be
the best course of action I mean if I
had to do all over again I wouldn't have
done this at all I would never have done
this and they put myself in debt like
this it's taking forever to pay off yeah
on my financing and all that well I want
you to know we have all done a lot of
dumb things with money you're not the
first one so don't feel too special and
know that this is one of the better I'm
not going to say good types of debt but
better because it's somewhat reversible
because we can actually sell this you
can't sell your degree that has student
loans attached so that's what we want
you to do your homework on and figure
out from Kelley Blue Book go to kbb.com
find out the actual value you can get
private to sell it and if it's less than
30 then we need to make up the
difference with some cash quickly how
much money do you have in the bank
account
right now it's
so I've been I've been out of I did
something even more dumb I I left work
without actually securing my new job but
yeah great right
um so I only have five five thousand
right now that's great I thought you
were gonna say five dollars
uh no okay Brandon stop beating yourself
up that's A1 is to stop beating yourself
up and go listen we did some dumb things
we're gonna clean this mess up we're
never gonna do it again
well that's the only time when it's done
when you keep doing it over and over yes
okay I know you I know you got to look
into this because this van is a very
unique van you can like live in it
basically so so if you were to like just
throw a number out like even lowball it
like you think you can get 15 grand for
it
I think someone will buy it for 15 20.
10. I think the biggest problem for me
would be to actually find somebody this
is a very really Niche sort of thing
right now so how special is this thing
well isn't it well it's not like it used
as a work then yeah yeah if you just
what if you took everything out right
did you already convert it
yeah that's the thing and I only have
about I just have to finish the shower
and uh maybe a bit of Plumbing but other
than that I wouldn't put I wouldn't put
any more money in it
right I feel like that would be a bad
idea yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't I would
let someone else finish it out that once
there's another Brandon out there who
has a dream to live in the van who who
is actually going to go through with
this hey on Instagram it looks glorious
via Instagram well I say no I know I
know I know okay so so let's just
pretend let's just lowball it let's just
say you can get 20 for this at least and
this is a pretty much is this a brand
new van
okay I know I just want to give him like
worse like let's just pretend worst case
scenario very optimistic I love it let's
go let's go 15 grand let's just pretend
you can sell it for 15 grand okay you're
gonna still owe 15. you're gonna be able
to put some money some of the savings
that you have so now your debt's down to
like 10 you want to keep a thousand
bucks so I guess that's more like 11
000. yeah and then Brandon you're gonna
work you're gonna work extra you're
gonna be working nights you're going to
be working weekends you're going to work
work work uh I'm not mad at you still
staying at your parents for eight for
just a period of time on a plan knowing
okay I can pay all of this off I'm
living on nothing I'm gonna throw the
rest of this 15 I'm gonna get paid off
in three months and I'm going to be
moving out of my parents January 1. my
goal is to rent somewhere rent I don't
want you buying it right to rent
somewhere yeah to rent somewhere and
then and then save up uh you know for a
big emergency fund a down payment during
all that time uh and then you can look
ahead at buying but Brandon you could be
in a totally different position in six
months you really could I feel like
you're you sound you sound down on
yourself you sound hopeless but when you
run numbers and again I did worst case
scenario for the band maybe someone will
pay 25 000 for it and that is a whole
other wonderful thing that gets you to
spice up the description on Craigslist
to like yeah to forward on this tiny
home on Wheels yeah right anyways I
think Brandon in six months if you
really stay focused you have a written
out plan Drive the crappy car your
parents have for a little bit yes you
know that's I think that's totally fine
uh if they're willing to do that and
assist in that and then save up and buy
your own car I mean there's some pieces
in here that can work especially since
you're able to work nights you're able
to work weekends you don't have a lot of
expenses is you really in six months
could have a totally different life
financially and otherwise I love it and
we want to help you out Brendan we're
going to send you Financial Peace
University for free that it will include
every dollar premium it's going to get
you on a budget I want you to watch all
the video lessons to get fired up about
getting yourself out of the situation
and never ever going back into debt
again or cheering you on man hang on the
line Austin will pick up we'll hook you
up with financial peace and every dollar
thanks for the call this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by Oracle including Ramsey
Solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory HR planning budgeting and more
All in One dashboard go to netsuite.com
Ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jump start your CFO career
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined today by my fellow Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz and we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Cameron joins
us up next in Poughkeepsie Cameron
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call how are you
guys doing well how can we help today
and a year out of college and have some
savings built up beyond my emergency
fund I'm wondering what the best way for
me to invest these extra savings are
I was going to take out a mortgage on a
small condo
but learn that I will not be eligible
for a manual underwriting mortgage for
at least a year from now
okay why is that
I don't have the payment History built
up yet oh okay
so where are you living now are you
renting
I'm renting a room in someone's house
okay are you sure that qualifies towards
the payments
for manual underwriting sure okay I'm
not sure I would just contact A lender
to make sure that that counts and that
there's proof that you have proof of
payments because you're renting a room
out of someone's house versus it being
kind of a landlord situation is that
your landlord the person you're living
with
or is there someone else
okay yes they're the landlord and so
what's your question today
um what is the wisest way for me to
invest
um my extra savings how much do you have
I have um 10K in an emergency fund and
um a little over 30k in a savings
account cool that's great were you going
to use the 30k as a down payment for a
home
yes okay then honestly uh Cameron I
wouldn't I wouldn't invest it I would
just keep it where it is parked for it's
just going to be a year
until you can get your payment plan or
proof of proof of bills for manual
underwriting and then just put that 30k
and then continue to build it up this
year I mean if you're able to put even
more cash to put a larger down payment
because you've done great I mean you
have an emergency fund in place uh you
may want to beef that up a little bit if
you want depending on you know what you
think the maintenance and stuff is going
to be for something like a condo but
it'll be it'll be one more year and I I
don't like to invest it I don't like to
put my money and invest if I know I'm
going to use it within four to five
years so I would keep it where it is
keep going along and then next summer
you'll be able to to buy something yeah
and you're one year out of college are
you sure you want to stay in the
Poughkeepsie area long term
um I'm not totally sure but my job is
here and I really enjoy it cool how much
do you make
98. awesome that's great 98 with no debt
means you can put away a lot of money
over the course of the next 12 months
right
um yeah but my take home pay isn't as
it surprisingly lower than I
would expect is that due to investing in
taxes and health care
um I guess in taxes mostly in some
Health Care yeah are you getting a tax
refund every year
yes okay I might look at adjusting your
withholdings to uh increase your
take-home pay and that way we don't have
the government sitting with our money
all year long and then giving it back to
us that could help
okay yeah instead of getting a big tax
refund the money will be back in your
where it should be back in your paycheck
um but also I think too Cameron just to
say it out loud like there is a reality
that hits when you do
go into the workforce and you do see
taxes and you're like oh oh that's home
okay that that that's what it looks like
it sounds good and then when you when it
hits your account you're like wow
especially in certain States like New
York like New York I mean you guys yeah
it's it's a lot so uh that for sure that
for sure is a reality but I would keep
um going along and making sure that the
condo you buy next year is on a 15-year
and that it's that your payments no more
than a fourth year take-home pay and I
think you're doing great Cameron you're
you're out of college
um there's not a rush you're good you're
good so those kids you're out of college
do not have forty thousand dollars in
the bank and no debt that's right so you
are way ahead of the game I would keep
stacking up cash crunch the numbers like
Rachel mentioned to see how much down
payment do I need in order to have that
mortgage payment be no more than a
quarter of my take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed doing manual underwriting and I
would get in touch with Churchill and
just say hey Churchill Mortgage here's
what I'm trying to do I want to get a
house a year from now I want to make
sure that I'm doing this all by the book
so that when I go through the manual
underwriting process there's no issues
and that will give you a great game plan
of what you need how much money you need
to have down in order to I want I want
you to have at least 20 down could you
do that in your area
yes awesome that puts you in a great
spot where you're not paying PMI private
mortgage insurance and you're going to
be very young and be a homeowner and
then pay that thing off probably by your
early 30s at the latest awesome with an
income like that way to go man thanks so
much for the call
all right Don joins us up next in Flint
Michigan Don welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you guys doing today doing
great how can Rachel and I help
uh yeah so I'm recently looking to buy
my first home but I am very interested
in real estate investing and I am very
intertwined with it so right now I'm not
sure if I should potentially go smaller
so that I can save more and start real
estate investing sooner within the next
year or two or if I should kind of go
bigger set that foundation for like more
of a family home so that went by kid
when me and my wife were already in the
next three to five years to be ready for
you know to have kids and already we
feel like it'll be easier to pay off a
bigger home between the two of us before
we stop start popping out kids and
things like that you know we could work
more hours and get it paid off sooner
and things of that no [ __ ] and the
bigger home would only take us about six
years to pay off so it's kind of and
we're only 24 so both of us
what's your income household
okay so household income last year we
did 150 this year we're on track to to
do about 2 30. wow fantastic great job
okay so where are you guys living right
now
um right now we're renting in Michigan
in Auburn Hills especially okay how much
money do you have in the bank
um I have about 50 000 in the bank and
my wife has about I believe 10K in the
bank okay
what's the reason you guys have your
finances separate
um we actually recently just got married
so we haven't
like fully integrated fully yet okay
also she's really adamant on taking care
of like uh we weren't supposed to get
married until she graduated paid off her
student loans and stuff but we decided
to make the jumps sooner and she's real
adamant on you know being independent
and taking care of that because that's
something she's always thought of doing
by herself
yeah yeah things like that you know so
how much does she have left yes yeah 16
000 left and with the whole bidening
thing going on we're actually expecting
maybe to wait to see if he follows
through we don't really trust them but
at the end of the day we're waiting to
see if they um follow through or whatnot
also she had zero percent interest up
into I think 2023 sometime into 2023 so
do you guys have any other kind of debt
car loans credit cards
um
she yes we also have
um 4 000 left on her car now okay and
that's it so we're talking twenty
thousand dollars of debt total
yeah and you guys have sixty thousand
dollars in the bank
just about yes okay now 15 of that I I
like I don't 13 of that is technically
my emergency front Okay so it's called
35 you have liquid yeah yeah I would say
yeah I don't need 15 as an emergency
fund though I really only need about 10
at most to be honest but okay well
looking at these numbers here's what
I'll tell you based on the Ramsay plan
that has helped tons of people build
wealth and invest in real estate is that
I want you completely debt free fully
funded emergency fund and then we're
gonna buy our primary house first pay
that off okay then we can get into real
estate investing so I love that you guys
want to do this but it's going to be
delayed if you want to do it the smart
way
okay now if you want to get like a
duplex or something those that might be
hard to find because you're not the
first one to have a genius idea of
having duplex or you know having a
multi-family home but you could do that
and have the mortgage payment be
reasonable 25 and then have someone live
on the other side too I would I would
encourage you guys and encourage her
that you know once y'all y'all are
married y'all are a team it's not her
debt my debt and I understand her pride
and like I can do this but listen
there's no more I in life anymore it is
a Wii and you guys together can make
progress so much faster so today today I
would pay off the student loans I'd pay
off the car keep the emergency funds and
then you'll have 35 000 for a down
payment on a great home and I would just
go for it you guys work together as a
team you can get there so much faster if
you want to go fast go alone if you want
to go far go together this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more firsts
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we take a whole lot of calls about real
estate on the show and right now you're
hearing a lot of Talking Heads in the
news stirring up fear about the real
estate market and if you believe them
you think the housing market is going to
crash and it's going to be a repeat of
the 2008 housing crisis but you're not
hearing the truth and you can't make
decisions based on fear you need the
facts and here they are in 2008 there
was a huge supply of homes but not
enough buyer demand so home prices
dropped but that's not what's happening
in today's market right now there is
half as many homes for sale in twice as
many buyers this means home prices
aren't going down anytime soon they're
just growing at a slower rate we're
seeing all these over asking inflated
prices come back down to reality so if
you're ready to buy or sell a home you
don't need to wait you can still win in
this market but you need a pro in your
corner you need to work with an
experienced real estate agent and we've
done the hard work of vetting those
agents who know your local market and
have the transactions to back it up
they've got the receipts so if you want
to connect with a Ramsay trusted agent
for free go to ramseysolutions.com agent
and check out our endorsed local
providers program again that's
ramseysolutions.com agent
I'm George Campbell joined by Rachel
Cruz today we're taking your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five Veronica joins us up next in
Chicago Veronica welcome to the show
thank you so much guys for taking my
call I just have a question I'm
definitely right now but I think I feel
like I'm stuck
um my budget I have to keep borrowing
money from my emergency fund and then
put in a bag when I get paid and my next
step is to pay off my mortgage or put
extra money towards my mortgage but I
can't seem to find the money so I don't
know what I'm doing wrong guys I'm
looking for your help
well thanks for the call and uh congrats
on becoming debt free and so right now
you're saying you don't have the margin
so you keep going back to the emergency
fund because you can't pay all of your
bills without dipping into it
well I am able to play a month but I
have to dip into it and then when I get
my last paycheck of the month I pay you
back okay so you're you're saying when
you're going to do your budget it's not
being planned in a way where you can
actually pay all the bills at the right
times
that's true
all the bills that I have for the month
but I have to borrow from my emergency
fund and then when I get that next check
pay it back do you have any buffer I'm
doing something wrong do you have any
buffer in your checking account right
now
I know so you're basically running it
down to zero and then going I have to go
to the emergency fund yes so what if we
started your checking account at 500 and
you treat that like zero that becomes
your new Baseline and then we start to
budget based off of that would that help
okay yeah I think it's a good idea
because I'm like how am I gonna stop
paying bills if I'm my first paycheck is
until like the first week or the second
week of the month sometime yeah that's
where you got to find margin that's when
and it may take you you know a month or
two just to cut any expenses you can
Veronica to get a surplus there in your
checking account because yeah you're
going it's going backwards I hear what
you're saying and so we want to be going
forward and not touching the emergency
fund and so
um so yeah that I mean for me I would
look at my budget and say okay I'm gonna
cut this this and this keep that saved
uh where I'm not spending that out
whether it's cutting subscriptions you
cut your food budget down again this is
one or two months this is to catch you
up so that you are a paycheck ahead in
your checking account to tactically pay
the bills and then when your other
paycheck hits you can use that for the
bills that are yeah let's go in the
right direction but if you had the
margin pay off the debt you should now
have that same margin to pay your bills
and get ahead and invest and pay off the
house early right
well I'm already putting 15 of myself
and my husband
doing that already we're putting a
little bit for a college fund for our
daughters but then it's like a month
there is nothing left to send extra to
the mortgage it's tight beyond that
exactly but I do get a quarterly
commission paycheck so I'm thinking even
if I have to wait every quarter and put
that extra money towards the mortgage or
I don't know
you could use that bonus and get a month
ahead in your budget toward you have the
next month's budget ready to go in your
checking account that can be very
helpful to a lot of people where that
becomes an issue but I think truthfully
this is a budgeting issue are what are
you using right now to create your
budget and track
I'm using the dollar app and I I do get
behind sometimes you know adding the
transactions that I'm using every month
but I'm using the dollar app and my
daughter started working this weekend
she's 16 years old and she's already
into the budget app and everything oh
that's awesome but uh well there's a new
feature anymore now that you told me
that every dollar which is what you just
mentioned they our team just released a
brand new feature called paycheck
planning and it solves this very issue
so you can go into every transaction and
go hey this bill falls on this part of
the month and they do all the math for
you to show you where that would fall
how much money you're going to have when
that money would run out and then you
can adjust based on that so it's a great
new feature make sure you have that app
updated and check that out I think that
will help a ton is that with a
subscription or I can still get that
feature with a basic color app that's a
great question I may be with premium but
what I'm going to do is gift you one
year of Premium on the house so that you
can check that out and get ahead with
this budget how's that sound thank you
so much guys I really appreciate it
thank you for all the tips and advice
these has really changed my life and I'm
showing it to everybody I know because
it's a life-changing thing for us oh we
appreciate that well you change your
life forever thank you for that hang on
the line Austin will pick up we'll make
sure that we send you one year of every
dollar premium and we're gonna also send
you one year of Financial Peace
University to keep you motivated along
the way thanks so much Julie joins us up
next in Atlanta Julie welcome to the
show
um thank you can you hear me okay you
sound great what's going on okay
um so before we started the baby steps
in the Ramsey plan earlier this year um
we had several years worth of IRS debt
so we took out a HELOC against our home
and threw all of those in there
um our home is worth about 430
000 uh we still owe to 32 8. so the
t-lock currently is only 27.6
um and some change however we also had
previously two years ago taken out a
consolidation loan which has a balance
of 33 8 and that percentage rate is like
7.25 whereas the HELOC you know will be
locked in at four percent
um so we're just not sure if it would be
smart to roll that into it at a lower
interest rate and just make that loan
part of our you know part of the HELOC
and or snowball that way or I know
that's going against equity in our home
and that's a little more risky so I'm
just not sure how to do the order of the
snowball and whether to just make that
part of the HELOC and and then pay your
truck off first or where to go what's
left on the truck
um 94
um and that's at 3.49 it's it would be
paid off
you owe 94 000. no no no no
nine thousand four oh my gosh I about
how to panic at the nicest that's a
great truck that's a great you better be
living in that truck
okay what's your income household income
buddy
um our household income is about 140 a
year okay
um monthly is 11 6 is what we bring home
11 6 is your take-home pay
yes uh-huh and how much of that can we
throw at all this debt if we really
tighten up get on an every dollar budget
um we and that that's where we've paid
off credit cards and we're you know
trying to put at least you know 1500 you
know every month towards you know of
course our minimum payment on the
consolidation loan and uh do you have
more debt you said what's on the credit
card
um those are those were paid off with
the consolidation law so we have nothing
left on credit cards it's just these
three the he locked the truck and then
the consolidation line have you cut up
the credit cards
oh yes
good good good okay yeah well I would
just still keep them separate Julie
because with a HELOC if you can pay it
off if it's if it's half your annual
income then keeping it separate instead
of rolling it into your mortgage and
everything I would so I would just uh
okay yeah I would just put that into
that small versus pushing it some HELOC
so we'd say push the baby step six uh if
it's more than half of your annual
income but you guys uh it's not so I
would keep it I would keep it in the
debt snowball and part of the reason I
would not roll it in is part of what got
you into this mess was this idea that if
we're rolling in it'll be smart and we
can move this over here and we're doing
some fancy math but there's only one way
to get rid of the debt and that's to get
rid of the debt and so I'm gonna use as
much of that 11-6 take home pay as I can
to attack the car and that's going to be
gone real soon with your income then
we're going to go after that HELOC at
27. okay yeah so put the truck ahead of
that other 27 that's in that heat
smallest the largest regardless of the
interest rate that is what's going to
get you debt free as fast as possible
with the most progress and keep you guys
motivated along the way
great job Julie you guys got this thank
you we believe in you
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined today by
Rachel Cruz this is the Ramsay show it's
a free call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's talk about your
life and your money Steven joins us up
next in San Antonio Stephen welcome to
the show
hey how are you all doing doing great
how can we help
good
um so I'll dive right into it my wife
and I are morally opposed to the student
loan forgiveness we feel like we are
stealing ten thousand dollars from other
people
um so even though my wife would benefit
by receiving ten thousand dollars
um do you think it would be unwise if we
were to not apply or to opt out of it
the other thing is when we feel like
this would kind of put like an asterisk
by our debt-free screen when that day
comes so what are your thoughts I think
that's a great take and I've used the
analogy that if I train for a marathon
for months and I woke up early and I ran
in the rain and I ran that Marathon got
to the Finish Line got my medal and
Rachel Cruz over here gets an Uber to
the finish line for the last stretch and
then she gets a medal too I'm gonna be a
little bit miffed but here's the thing I
know I earned it and Rachel knows that
she cheated it it's like in the office
that Marathon episode it's exactly what
happened to us so to your credit Stephen
I think there's a lot of dignity and in
just paying it if you want to do that
and that's what you feel morally you're
led to do but there's also nothing
immoral about applying for it and
getting it so that's my stance Rachel
probably disagrees vehemently no I don't
even though some people think I do uh no
I mean I I again I don't think it's a
moral issue Stephen now values of kind
of what you value you and your wife
um in your journey which your value
about the hard work and knowing that we
did this like all of that right
um uh I get that I totally get that so
if that's a value set that you guys have
then you guys pay it off yourselves it's
great but I don't think it's immoral if
you take it I don't think it's neces you
know it's quote unquote wrong
um and I do and I would say too I
wouldn't
um and even people listening I don't
think it gives I don't know maybe we
disagree on this George I don't think it
gives an asterisk because I feel like
we've had people on debt free scream
stage that say well
you know
um my parents gifted US 10 grand
uh through this thing and we used it to
pay off the credit cards and the car and
so we got to jump and then we got to pay
off the student loans fast like whatever
the story may be right like that that
sometimes happens and I don't put an
asterisk on their story I just say wow
what a gift what a blessing to your
debt-free situation and you got out of
debt that much faster that's great do
you know what I'm saying so I don't want
you it doesn't take away from your
achievement and what you guys think yeah
I don't I don't think it would if if you
do apply and you decide to do that but
if you guys like again I said this on
the show two days ago and people got all
mad at me but a girl called and she had
the money to pay it off and I said then
pay it I think I just paid off because
you have the money it's there
um so I get that there's a team member
literally we were talking about it yeah
two days ago and he they have the money
and they right they're gonna write a
check on Monday to pay after student
loan and his wife was like we are not
taking this we are paying it off now you
know so again it's not a moral immoral
thing I think it's just a values-based
decision that you and your wife and it
sounds like from what you're saying that
you're like I don't feel good taking it
so then I wouldn't I wouldn't you
started the question that way of I'm
morally opposed so like Dave said on air
yesterday if you've been publicly
opposing this thing yes it feels
hypocritical to then go take it but
there's nothing wrong with doing it
you're no better than anyone who did
take it but there's nothing wrong with
doing that if that sets you guys up
you're applying it to the baby steps
it's not like you guys are sitting
around waiting on a handout you guys
have worked the plan and you're doing
this thing and if you use that money to
propel your financial Journey we're
sincerely happy for you so have you guys
paid it off already
uh no we we haven't paid it off we have
about uh probably about 42 000 left 12
000 sitting in excess savings because we
just had a baby and um so so yeah so
this would help us but yeah but yeah
yeah I think it's a good call in your
gut you don't feel good about it and you
know it doesn't feel right then don't
you guys can you you can work and pay it
off for sure for sure but if you were so
convicted about this then don't lose
sleep over it so that's on the other
side but there's nothing wrong with
doing that like if he's gonna feel
convicted because he got the forgiveness
and now he's feeling guilty about it and
it is opposing his moral values it's not
worth it to apply for it that's totally
that's what I'm saying yeah for sure for
sure there's nothing wrong with this
propelling your financial journey and
just seeing it as a gift from from Uncle
Sam it falls on potentially the
taxpayers we just don't know such a hard
it's such a hard conversation as we're
like stumbling over the the feelings of
all the answers no because I mean again
it's a reality that it's out there
whether you agree it's a reality or not
it's out there now there's all this
stuff of like is it gonna have to pass
through Congress and Supreme Court and
how are they paying for this there's a
lot well we know yeah well we don't
they're saying it could come from the
the deficit that apparently oh it could
be creating this year okay okay so
anyways we don't truly know what this
looks like and again it's this weird
juxtaposition of like it's gonna if it's
there yeah do you take it and see it to
propel your life forward then that's
great but if you don't feel good about
it and you want to just Propel your own
life forward that's great so we don't
have an answer for you Rachel this feels
just like the whole like we dealt with a
thousand calls about the vaccine and
should I it's just like it goes back to
your moral value yeah totally absolutely
so thanks for the call Stephen it's a
great question it is I would go with
your gut Stephen I would go with the
value set of your family because that's
how we make decisions so again it's not
a moral issue it's a values question for
you and your wife and if you're leaning
one way I would take that spirit and
that gut and I'd follow that so that's
what I would do good question thanks for
it Phil joins us up next in Philadelphia
I think that's apropos Phil welcome to
the show
hey guys thank you so much for having me
um I been plugged in since the to the
Ramsey Network since uh 2021 and and in
the process of plugging in I've been
able to grow in of course in financial
uh in my financial life but in other
areas of my life and I I was I've been
really appreciative for that I'm trying
to continue to grow
um as a leader I'm in a position of
leadership in my my job and I want to
grow as a leader and I was just curious
if you guys have any book
recommendations that I could plug into
to uh accomplish that that's an awesome
question and we probably have too many
books so I guess it's probably best to
go by authors and then we can throw out
a few recommendations that's fair yeah
um for leadership I'll let Rachel go
first so I don't want to steal her
Thunder okay
uh Jim Collins obviously he's a great
one anything that that he's written
great uh yep my my favorite book and I
think it's Patrick lincione that wrote
it ideal team player it's one that we
use hungry yeah we use that you just
stole my thunder I'm not kidding Georgia
no so it's a great especially if you're
a leader it talks about the ideal team
player and they need to be hungry they
need to be humble and they need to be
smart and not like intelligent smart but
people smart relationally smart so these
three things are so key so if you're
having someone on your team that's
struggling it's just a great filter to
use and all of us have strengths and
that weaknesses but that's the one
tactically Phil that I feel like I I use
just in my head that I've learned so
much from but that was Patrick right
that wrote it absolutely okay so ideal
team player Jim Collins now you go great
friends of ours uh I'm gonna go Leaders
Eat Last from Simon sinek yeah we're big
Simon sinek fans and we're Big Jim
Collins fans and big Pat linchione fans
yes and of course Henry Cloud I got to
mention boundaries for leaders yeah
another great book for leadership growth
and on top of that we have to mention
the OG entree leadership have you read
that one Phil
I I have it's a great one and the
podcast uh on Charlie sure podcast which
are on George I do host that so that
feels like a great pitch
um but we do have a bunch of leadership
books on our website as well Phil so if
you want to jump on ramseysolutions.com
in the store we have a lot of non-ramsy
books that we just Dave is a huge fan of
these books our leadership team has read
these books and so we recommend them to
our folks and fans
awesome thank you and yeah from the
entree leadership podcast I picked up uh
and have read take the stairs by Rory
um and after listening to your your
interview with him and um yeah I just I
mean you know the scales have dropped
from my eyes sort of experience and
plugging in all these resources it's
just been super helpful so thank you
guys very much that's awesome awesome to
hear man that's so cool part of our
passion here at Ramsay yeah is not just
it's not just the money stuff it really
is the the whole part in leadership is a
big is a big message that we have here
that we as we run this company right
here at Ramsay Solutions uh we're all in
it together every day and it's it's a
big part of toxic money culture and
there's a toxic leadership culture and
if we can get better leaders then we'll
have better team members who are engaged
who can create more impact in this
economy and in this world so we love
that appreciate you listening to this
show and entree leadership Phil thanks
so much that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to
all of the folks in the booth the Bro
Booth as we now call it because Kelly
Daniel is no longer in the booth she's
all right we'll be back with you before
you know it this is the Ramsay show
it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the Ramsay
show if you want to do your debt free
scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
from Ramsey Network this is the Ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living wild I'm
George Campbell your host joined today
by Rachel Cruz best-selling author
Ramsay personality host of The Rachel
Cruz show and we are here for you
America taking your calls about life and
money triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to call and
Megan is kicking us off this hour in
Dallas Texas Megan welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are y'all we're happy to take it
doing great how can we help
okay so excuse me so
um from growing up as a kid my parents
always taught me to save my money and to
not go into debt and they're both our
Finance and Accounting majors and so I'm
going to college this fall and so I've
been saving my money and I have a little
under 15 000 and then I have about third
I'm sorry 3 000 from financial aid and I
plan on not working my first semester
and focusing on grades so that my next
semester I can get grandson scholarships
for grades and then get a job so my
question is how can I better balance
saving money and having fun in college
as well as stay in my budget
great question I love that you're even
asking this you were like one of the
most mature college students I've ever
encountered fantastic thank you so are
you is this college paid for
um so I'll be paying from I'll be paying
for it no no help from Mom and Dad no
savings there no cash flowing this yep
what does it cost each semester or each
year
um I think it's about tuitions like at
least for me it's like 2 000. 2000 a
semester yeah okay so we're talking four
grand a year for four years
yeah just about okay so that's 16 000
total and so that's our number we're
aiming for you have fifteen thousand in
the bank
right and you have three thousand which
is financial aid is that actual cash
that's like a Pell grant money okay
great sometimes I look back at my
financial aid package and it was a bunch
of loans so I just wanted to make sure
they weren't giving you a three thousand
dollar loan as a gift no no it's no
longer great and that's being applied to
your first year the three thousand
fall semester and then the rest goes to
Winter okay cool and then where are you
living
I'll be living like on campus does that
and that's not included in the tuition
so how are you paying for that
[Music]
uh okay and do you know how much that
costs each year
um
not sure how much it is per year okay do
you know per semester
um per semester is
um 1359.
cool I'm not trying to pop quiz you here
I'm trying to figure it out no you're
good are you going to be able to cash
flow it and if so is there any money
left over and what kind of good time are
we going to need to have here what are
your actual expenses going to be in
college do you have a meal plan through
the school
no I'll be making my own food awesome
okay living on campus making your own
food so we need a food budget
right and beyond that you're going to
need some a little bit of fun money and
are you paying any other expenses do you
have a car there is there fuel insurance
no my parents I'm on my family plan for
insurance and then I won't have a car so
it'll just I'll just be walking
everywhere okay cool and a cell phone
uh nope I'm not a famous fan okay it's
cool so I would have you made a budget
yet to put this all on paper and figure
out what it's going to look like
um I have like partly I just I I haven't
put everything together of like all my
expenses and like food budget or the
rent for like the full year I haven't
done that yet
cool well we're gonna gift you one year
of every dollar premium so that you can
make that plan for every single dollar
you have coming in every dollar you have
because the goal here is cash flow
college and the second goal is let's
have a good time and have some margin
with money to have fun and have some
entertainment in there as well and not
be you know but you should be struggling
as a college student that's normal but
you can also have fun while you're at it
yeah and Megan you're in a great
position I'm really proud of you I mean
you got fifteen thousand dollars saved
you have some grant money like you said
and then you're gonna be working you're
gonna be able to do all of this and
you're living is great I mean 1300 per
semester I mean that's that's wonderful
um you know from a from a budgeting
standpoint and you have the money I mean
it's just it all is Flowing really well
and I think for you it's just to be to
stay on top of it and to have a plan and
I can tell even by the way you're asking
these questions is to make sure that
when you have money to yeah have a great
time which is part of college too right
and so budgeting that though to give you
the freedom and the reassurance and the
peace to know okay the big stuff is
taken care of so I actually can enjoy
myself with the money that I have for
fun money and to your point about not
working wanting to focus on your grades
I think it's great but I also found when
we did The Borrowed future podcast we
cited a study that found that if you
work 15 to 20 hours a week part-time
while in school they actually have a
higher GPA than those that don't work
is that shocking
that is yes and I think it makes sense
when you think about it because you go
well those people really need to have
some discipline they got budgeted all of
their time very wisely and therefore
they're not you know just frivolously
hanging out trying to have a good time
they're focused they're doing their
schoolwork they're going to work they're
having fun in the meantime and you can
still have a life and work 15 hours a
week in college and that could provide
enough to cash flow to where you have
money to have fun and so I think that
might be the antidote to this problem is
working because it allows you to have a
good time and if you find your grade
slipping because of work then dial it
back and let's take it take a semester
off of that
okay got it thanks so much for the call
we'll make sure Austin picks up and
Gifts you every dollar premium along
with that I'm going to give you
Financial Peace University watch it with
your friends in the dorm that'll be fun
right wow George actually you did that
yes when you were in college I'm sure
you were watching Financial Peace
University I was like oh yeah guys come
come here come here all my Kai Omega
sisters and I knew you were kyoming
we're gonna we're gonna watch this
lesson on dumping debt can I be honest
Rachel I didn't know like what a
sorority really was until I moved to the
South oh and I went to this private
little Christian College we didn't even
have like Greek life man it's a thing
like I didn't under I'm a middle eastern
I thought Greek life was like you eat
hummus like I didn't understand that
that's what it meant and so my wife went
to Arkansas she was Kai Omega she was on
the prom Squad yes you guys need to bro
down about that we need to do the secret
handbook but I'm still confused about it
okay here's the thing with sororities
and tell me prove me wrong set me
straight whatever you got to do I can I
can you pay a whole bunch of money
to friends to live basically in the
white house and have like servant people
bring you meals okay hold on
they had a private Chef I did the
University of Tennessee when I was there
they do now but we did not have
sorority houses we had a sorority dorm
the University of Tennessee because of
an old law in Tennessee which is about
saying that a certain number of women
legally could not live in a house so
they had to like get the law yes kind of
old time Tennessee you know there's
random laws in in states that it's like
wait what like it's one of those so
interesting somehow they got it removed
or whatever so now the University of
Tennessee does have sorority dorms we
did not we had dorms and I did so I did
sorority and I did Young Life I was a
young life leader so I I did you
balanced mix of all of it but it was a
great time I mean I it was so funny I
believe it Whitney says the same thing
but I'm like that sets you up for
failure to live in a really nice house
have everyone cooked for you and do your
laundry the rooms look like dorm rooms
though in these houses they're not like
it's not like legally blondes to the
University of Arkansas are you look are
you thinking of Legally no I'm not I'm
never thinking
never they look beautiful but the inside
are like dorm rooms we're gonna get the
show back on the rail soon folks more of
it coming up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined today by Rachel Cruz
just a moment ago Rachel and I were
talking about sororities I do not
understand them she was trying to help
me understand them I thought they don't
set you up for adult life because
someone is cooking for you and doing
your laundry I'm like isn't that what
you should be learning to do in college
so you can be an adult and then Rachel
Cruz dropped uh just dropped a bomb in
the conversation what happened Rachel I
know because you're not truly a coyote
are you
I dropped the end of my junior year
because I was engaged to Winston no not
just for him but I'm like I was engaged
I was interning at Ramsay I was speaking
I was like I'm I'm kind of I was done
with college I was like I'm ready to
move on to adult life all of it so I
didn't want to go to the meetings if you
don't go to the meetings you get fined
it's this whole thing I don't even know
if you knew that George chip it's true
and so anyway so I I dropped and when
you dropped specifically Kai Omega they
make you turn in your PIN like I am not
a legacy anymore so I can't ride or the
cop turning in is bad I can't I can't
write a wreck for my girls like their
only Legacy they have my sister was a
coyote so she can write I don't use the
word legacy yes yes so all I have to say
all that to say technically in like the
legalistic world of so is sorority life
I technically am not a Kai Omega but I
was so if anyone has connections
to the president the president reach out
to Rachel on Instagram main like
headquarters is in Texas
there's a supreme government this is how
privilege sounds like wow oh ow
ouch James the producer said I did I
would I would rewind my life for a
minute ago and not have this
conversation but you know what this is
the elitist classism I expected oh my
gosh anyways that was my confession to
George that technically I'm claiming Kai
Omega and I can't claim it because I'm
technically not one
now Rachel you work and I wanted to to
move on with my I wanted to not be a
college student you love conspiracy
theory and I have a new one that
sororities and fraternities are scams
created by colleges to make more money
and keep you loyal to the alumni program
that's my hot take
uh I think false
and fraternities are a different thing
than sorority let's say that too uh-oh
yeah yeah I would say that okay let's
let's let's move on we didn't have beer
pong at my very Christian private school
Rachel okay we were good folks anyways
Maria's on the line she needs actual
help so we're gonna try to help Maria
out
in Toledo Maria how you doing
I'm fine thank you uh thanks for taking
my call sure
um my question is regarding uh our our
housing class me and my husband
um so last year we took a home equity
line of credit out
um to make major necessary repairs to
the house
um and we did that with the plan to sell
the house once the repairs were made
because the market was so tight right we
could get a ton for the house
um and so we made the repairs and we
lifted the house and started looking at
what we could afford and it turned out
that even if we spent as much as
the bank said we could afford the houses
were definitely a downgrade from what we
already had
um so we decided to take the house off
the market and stay put
um so there's the history okay currently
currently our house costs are like this
we owe 57 000 on our original mortgage
loan at 4.125 percent
and we owe 24 000 on the HELOC at 5.5
percent
but we got a call from the bank
reminding us that our HELOC interest
rate is variable although it would never
jump or decrease more than half a
percent at a time
we are currently paying 600 a month for
the original mortgage and 235 on the
HELOC per month
but money is so tight that the 835 a
month is really a problem for us we're
living paycheck to paycheck in using
savings and Credit to make up any
difference that each month may have
so I looked into refinancing in order to
combine the monthly payments into a
lower amount for us the interest rate
would be 5.25 percent
a 30-year refi would cost 659 a month a
20-year would cost 778 a month in a
15-year isn't really doable for us
because it would be it would be more it
would be 8.75 a month
so my question is I'm having trouble
deciding if it's the best option for us
to refinance because the original loan
interest rate was only 4.125 percent
so the rate on one loan is lower than
the current rate and the rate on that
other loan is higher so I wanted to get
your advice on should we refinance
well I'll tell you Maria based on
everything you just shared I'm less
worried about interest rate and more
worried about you guys living in a cycle
of paycheck to paycheck
once you guys make it make a year Maria
um we're a single uh income home my
husband makes
um about 55 000.
okay you guys have kids
we have three kids and I homeschool and
that is non-negotiable so
um
me going to work isn't really an option
to boost income
okay what does he do for work
um he does like audio visual in
you put in access key cards to get into
big businesses and stuff like that cool
does he work for a company
he does okay could he do side work you
know installing mounting TVs in the
neighborhood things like that with his
talent
he probably could and I have entertained
the idea of like cleaning houses
when he's home so yeah yeah I think we
need to get creative right now long term
we need to get income yeah and what
other debt what other debt do you guys
have
we uh have 3 000 in credit card debt now
we could technically pay for that we
have 8 000 in savings okay but like I
said
um we're living in a cycle where we have
to dip into savings fairly regularly so
it's
concerning to us to take that 3 000 away
I hear that we might need it
yes yeah I hear that okay is that the
only debt do you guys have any cars or
personal loans student loans
no okay
yeah so the biggest thing Maria is you
know when when it comes down to it you
just looking at the math that you guys
can't even with basically
where how you're living right now you're
not it's not working right the what the
money coming in is going right back out
and you're still in the red so you're
having to dip into savings and
um charging the charging some cell phone
credit cards so yeah the cycle has to
stop George is right and so you guys
have to get so disciplined and make some
changes you really do you have to be
able to say
okay uh either we're gonna have to up
this income of the 55 000 and that means
changing jobs I don't know what that
means for him but you guys have to bring
in more money that is sustainable
because you're you know we're not
talking about anything crazy here it's
not like you guys have two car payments
two student loans all this and when all
that gets paid off there's going to be a
lot of margin because you guys are down
to kind of just the Necessities is what
it feels like and so what's hard is to
create that margin there has to be
life change and that part of that could
be cutting expenses uh and upping income
those are the two big ways that money
flows money flows in and money flows out
and so looking at both of those is going
to be really really important and with
the math I would keep yeah the HELOC and
the mortgage separate and like George
said it's yeah the interest rate is it's
not gonna it's not gonna completely
change your life
um really having margin in your month to
month budget will uh it's going to
create breathing room and I think a big
part of that is income yeah and looking
at the numbers here 8 35 what's your
take-home pay
about 29 2 900. um
so we're talking almost a third of your
take-home pay as being eaten up by the
mortgage which the mortgage is 600 bucks
so what I would do honestly I'd pay off
the credit card today leaving with five
thousand dollars and then I'm cutting up
the cards and that's just not an option
anymore and we have to figure it out and
if we have any expenses come up we're
going to cash flow that and pause the
debt snowball as we attack the HELOC so
that would be your next goal is
completely wipe out that HELOC giving
you back 235 dollars in your life every
month and now we can breathe and now
this mortgage is Affordable and now we
can actually save for college and pay
off the house early and do all these
things so we want to help you along this
journey I'm going to gift you one year
of Financial Peace University and along
with that every dollar premium to help
you guys make a plan for every single
dollar coming in watch those videos as a
family get fired up and say no more
we're cutting up the cards debt is not
we're up in the income and up in the
income and that's temporary we once we
pay off the HELOC we can breathe we can
stop all the side jobs and enjoy life
again but right now it's go time you got
this hang on the line Austin will pick
up and we'll get to those gifts thanks
so much for the call this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
every time you hear someone do their
debt free scream on this show it's
because at some point they said enough
I'm not living like this anymore I've
had it and when you get mad like that
and do what they did your life will
change too and right now inflation your
stupid credit cards are killing you
you've started to believe you're not in
control of your money but you're wrong
you have to decide to control what you
can control and that's you your behavior
you have the power to change your future
and Financial Peace University will show
you how this course will teach you the
proven step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly 10 million people beat debt
Master budgeting and build wealth and
you can do it too guys stop letting debt
and money stress control your life say
enough and Take Back Control you can
start Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com enough that's
ramseysolutions.com enough Marty joins
us in Las Vegas Marty welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for grabbing my
call I'm so excited we are very much
excited too how can we help
so I had a lot for you guys
I got married about four going on five
years ago and I had purchased my house
my first house when I was 20 so before I
got married I had my own house then we
got married we bought a house together
and we bought a vehicle together
um about two years ago I sold that house
um and well first of all I worked my
butt off to pay it off so by the time I
sold it it was 100 uh free and clear
amazing
thank you yeah I I had to work really
really really hard
um to accomplish that and to even buy a
house at 20 I was the I yeah I
definitely had to work my butt off but
with um with that being said my husband
always said you know whatever you do or
don't do with that house like that's you
because you you did that I didn't have
like partake in it or he didn't put
money towards it and stuff like that so
now
um recently I've been you know kind of
like buckling down and trying to get him
more on the same page as finances as me
and two weeks ago we had this wonderful
conversation where I felt like oh my God
like you know we're going to move
forward together with finances and stuff
like that we are working on paying off
our debt the we don't have any credit
card debt the only debt that we have is
a car loan and then our house both of
those together are 258
000. which right now
um through the cell of the house and
then I own a small business I've always
been more of a saver I mean I like to
spend but I've also been diligent about
saving I have about 430 cash
um that now I brought up the fact that
well maybe I you know I should pay off
the house but my husband doesn't want me
to do that because he believes that that
is my money and that the house is ours
and we should be tackling that together
so another thing that I wanted to do
it's always been a dream of mine to own
um a beach condo or you know somewhere
like on the beach as a vacation and it
came an opportunity that we went to
Mexico about two months ago and I loved
where we stayed and they're building a
new development that's right on the
beach and they're selling condos there
so I wanted to go ahead and do that but
then I just don't I I already spoke to
my accountant and he said yeah you know
go ahead we looked at the numbers
um I could definitely pull it off but
then I kind of feel like I'm doing that
and I can pay off our house I just I
don't know you know which way to go
right now
great question well if I'm in your shoes
which is how we answer questions on this
show the car and the mortgage are paid
off today and we're going to celebrate
and you're going to tell your husband
listen
all of the good stuff and the bad stuff
from our past which in your case is good
stuff a paid for house is now our stuff
if you came in with student loan debt
and he said well I feel like that's your
student loan debt so you can pay that
it's the same situation on the flip side
you came in with a fully paid for house
and he gets the benefit of an awesome
wife with a paid for house and so this
is your money do you guys have combined
bank accounts
uh yeah so we have one combined bank
account and then we do have separate
um separate accounts each I guess one of
the things that may be and I don't know
if this would you know if this this
would matter so he was previously
married and he has two kids and then we
have two kids together so I always said
like my rental house
um it was basically going to be passed
on to my kids so he always said well you
know you know that's fine whatever you
want to do with that if you want to
inherit our kids all that money like you
know you can go ahead and do that or
whatever you wanted to do so I think
that's why he kind of feels like this
house is our house we should pay it off
together and then you could do whatever
you want with that many
um aside
yeah I mean I I I I hear what he's
saying but also I think more of it for
me Marty is is the spirit behind it and
it's still
playing this game of yours and mine
yours and mine yours and mine and and
the deal is when you get married this I
feel like it's become even more old
school advice which is just so funny to
me when you become married you just
become one in everything like we are
taking on each other's lives together
hand in hand and it's us together and
the and the fastest for you guys not
only to win financially but I think even
more importantly to to be United as a
couple it is it is all all of our chips
are in like we are we are all in this
together and the more you kind of like
split hairs between that and this and
well it's this that the more the the
division is just naturally going to be
there and so I think for the healthiest
marriage possible on the planet is to
say like we no matter what regardless
like what George said the good the bad
the ugly like we're locking arms and the
moment I say I do I am I am selflessly
giving my life up to join another person
that is that is the holy commitment of
marriage and and it's an amazing thing
when that starts to happen and so
um I would re I would I I would I would
sit down with him and just say hey this
is what I've been wrestling with and
what I think and I think all of us
combined you know to be able to have the
dream right to me the dream would be for
you a paid off house uh you know the car
paid for and a condo in Mexico that's a
dream I'm like heck yeah heck yeah so
how do we get there together well let's
pay off the mortgage when you don't have
a mortgage do you know how much you can
save every month from that when you
don't have a car payment a mortgage and
you're gonna you know you'll be able to
pay you'll still have money left over uh
from the cell of your house that you
guys can combine and say okay what will
it take to save up for this condo and
and you can just get to your dreams and
your goals so much faster when you're
not sitting there nitpicking everything
well that's yours like do this together
let's just make a huge explosion with
our lives and our money and like let's
get there let's get to Mexico pretty
much Rachel preach take
I'm curious
um so so he was he's a bartender at a
steakhouse so you know depending on tips
and stuff like that it varies and with
my small business I would probably say
we bring in around
150 a year give or take okay yep and how
much is the condo
uh the condo is uh 360. 360. okay so
yeah I'm like man you got a great jump
start once the mortgage is paid off and
the car is paid off to for this condo
and and you guys just killing it
together and paying cash for it here in
a few years and I just think it's I
think it's awesome so I love this plan
how much money do you guys have you know
you hit you have the 430 in cash from
the sale how much other liquid cash do
you have
well I have as far as liquid cash to
I think that's about yeah and that's
about it outside of the 430. outside of
the 430 and then outside of the 4 30 and
that's another thing
um retirement I have about 60.
cool
so what I would be doing I'm going to
lay out the plan very quickly and
clearly before we end here if you use
all the proceeds the 430 you pay off the
mortgage in the car today leaves you
with 172. you've got 10 000 in the
emergency fund now we can begin
investing 15 of our income into
retirement and that 172 becomes the the
starter fund for this condo which making
150 and your income will be increasing
over the next few years with no payments
in the world you guys can save up
another 100 200 000 and pay cash for a
condo within a few years
yeah and that's a decision we're going
to make together every financial
decision we make together including your
430 including his whatever we make every
decision together regardless of where
the money came from because we are one
we sleep in the same bed so let's make
decisions like that
yes you think thank you there you go
Mario I hope that you get through to him
you guys are crushing it so proud of you
guys this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the Day psalm 73 26 My
Flesh and my heart May Fail but God is
the strength of my heart and my portion
forever
Robin Williams once said there's no
shame in failing the only shame is not
giving things your best shot R.I.P
all right Dakota joins us up next in
Madison Wisconsin Dakota welcome to the
show
thank you George and Rachel I appreciate
you guys taking my call today absolutely
how can we help
all right so um I am in baby step one
currently
um and I'm looking for side hustles
um I and I was approached by a friend uh
of an opportunity
um to work with a company called
Primerica
um and they they mainly do work doing
term life insurance which is
um you know right up Dave's alley
um so I I everything that that he's he
was talking about sounded pretty good
um the only only kicker is that um it
costs about a hundred dollars for the
license to be able to
um sell the insurance
so I was wondering if if this would be a
good opportunity for a side hustle or
since I have to come out of pocket if I
and since I'm in baby step one if I
should try to find a more conventional
like maybe hourly paying job or you know
some other kind of side hustle instead
cool
it's a great question
um I'm trying to feel like I feel like
that they're set up almost like a
multi-level marketing stuff yeah yeah
which is probably why your buddy's
pitching this with insurance to get you
into this yeah
um is that does that sound right do you
like Insurance Dakota does it sound fun
or does the opportunity the money side
is that what kind of
but yeah so it is definitely it's mainly
the money side yeah um but
um he said that the company pretty much
um teaches Dave Ramsey principles and
you know I've been listening for years
um and pretty much cut my debt my debt
in half since listening but
um yeah I you know I'm interested in
learning more about life insurance
because you know eventually I'm going to
need it but it was mainly the money that
attracted me to it totally
um well with the setup of it I mean I
guess it's I think it's up to you I mean
there's a part of me that I kind of
always just like being a
site like just a one-to-one right as
just a regular employee versus kind of
being in a
uh
situation that you're I don't know the
way the money flows I don't know I'm not
100 confident and it is multi-level
marketing setup it is for sure because
I'm like based on recruiting and then
you can make money from the commissions
on insurance but truthfully I wouldn't
get tied up in it Dakota I think you can
make just as much money doing other side
hustles that don't pull you into this
that don't have initiation fees which is
a big way they make their money and so
I'm not mad at them it's a legitimate
company with a legitimate product that
we would recommend which is term life
insurance but I would steer you away
from that and on to something else that
you enjoy number one that can also pay
well so what are you doing right now
full time
um full-time I am a Bim drafter so I
basically do all the construction uh
documents for a home builder in
Wisconsin oh cool are there
opportunities outside of that where you
could do something similar in the
construction field
um do you have a
um yeah so I have a background in
carpentry which you know I love to to
build things there we go I've just been
a little bit leery about uh taking the
dive into
um trying to find my own jobs
everything's been kind of like stalined
or the work that I've done on the side
in carpentry has been through my father
so
um just a little nervous on that end
and nervous because you feel like you
have to invest in equipment like what
what's the or that you're not gonna have
many leads what's the what makes you
nervous
yeah a little bit a little bit of both
um I I mean I have most of the tools
that I would need to do basic jobs but
um yeah being able to find
um consistent work and then I'm not sure
how like insurance or if I need
insurance
um in order to to create a business
um starting off yeah but if you just
said one-off pieces for people
with that mate would that bring in good
money
for a site for a complete side hustle
for a side Hustle
yeah as long as I could keep on finding
the work yeah do you live in a
neighborhood Dakota
yeah it doesn't everybody exactly and
here's what I'm telling you in your
neighborhood there are several several
opportunities and once people get wind
that Dakota is is great with his hands
he does great carpentry work oh man I
need a table built oh man I need the
shelving built you will have leads out
your eyeballs but you won't be able to
keep up with the work because of how
busy you are
so that's something I would recommend
there's probably a Facebook group for
your community somewhere I would jump in
there and say hey I'm Dakota
um you know I got a side hustle I'm a
carpenter I can build this this and this
here's some of my work and as soon as
you do some good work that word gets
around and that can be some great side
money that could be way more than you
would have made with this Primerica deal
okay so believe in yourself man you got
a great skill that not a lot of people
have these days and a lot of people want
that so I would start there and you can
do a side hustle you can do ubereats and
doordash and dog sitting babysitting dog
walking mow Lawns there's so many ways
you can make money so do something right
now that you can start today and then
try to get this carpentry side hustle
off the ground
okay okay for sure yeah we're cheering
you on on the debt free journey man
thank you I appreciate it I appreciate
it um just one more quick question
um do you guys I mean I this might get a
little bit too in-depth but you guys
happen to know if or when I would need
insurance as a contractor
that's a great question I would reach
out to a carpenter in your area and see
if they'd be willing to kind of Mentor
you get coffee and say hey here's how I
built my business here's the point
here's the thresh if you're wanting to
do this full-time decoder just as a side
Hustle
um well eventually I I like to own my
own um Home Building Company but okay
um yeah yeah so I would say if you're
gonna go down that road then George is
right yeah find someone that's doing
what you want to do and just say hey in
the next five years it's a dream of mine
for that but for this point to get you
out of debt to pay the rest of your debt
off just as a side hustle just to build
some stuff and and sell it
um yeah you wouldn't need insurance but
if you're going to start a full-blown
business then yeah that's a whole other
a whole other discussion
um but yeah that's awesome so I think
one thing too to
uh Circle back to not Primerica
specifically but a lot of people do
multi-level marketing and a lot of women
do that in you know if you're staying at
home and all that and so always my my
word of advice with that stuff is we're
a lot of people make the money is the
ones that get in not just early but
they're recruiting so so if you feel
like oh I'm really passionate about
makeup I'm really passionate about
vitamins or whatever the thing is to
make money good money lots of money in
those companies it's not about the
products themselves and selling them it
really is the recruiting side so always
just knowing that ahead of time because
I feel like I've talked to
many people and they're like oh man you
know we paid the the fee to there was no
promises yeah not just to get in but
also to buy the product and all you know
so on and so forth and then I got in and
you're burned out five months later
because you realize oh wow it wasn't as
selling the product wasn't the main
thing it really is a recruiting tool so
just as I work you know not right wrong
or indifferent but I think that's just
like a lot of them require a lot of
upfront money you have to buy a certain
amount of product and then you're stuck
with that product and if you want to get
some real Insider information Google the
company name and then income disclosure
and what you'll find is they legally
have to disclose how much people make
and 98 of people don't make enough to
live off of doing this and a lot of
people are doing it a side Hustle but
very few are making forty fifty sixty
thousand dollars doing these MLM gigs so
that makes me very leery on top of the
fact that there's a lot of money you
have to put in yeah we're not mad at
home but I just I do want people to be
there's so much good products and you
know what it is yeah I don't want to
lump them all into a one bad bucket but
it's important to know because I think
it's always a conversation going on but
it wouldn't be my first choice for a
side hustle if you're in baby step two
and you need money quick and your Dakota
and your makes them like do you know how
much money people would make if you're
in the trades I'm telling you in my
neighborhood Facebook group if you are
if you work well you show up on time you
do good work you have good people skills
you are going to be like the the
townsperson carpenter so I love it good
for you Dakota awesome that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show and the books my
thanks to my fantastic co-host Rachel
Cruz all the folks in the booth Austin
Ben James Zack's in there Andrew's in
there the whole game keeping the show
flow in new America we appreciate
listening we'll be back with you before
you know it until then spend wisely save
intentionally and give generous
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]